la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
aterrizó en taiwán la visita tensiona
aún más las relaciones entre washington
y beijing que reaccionó con maniobras
militares en torno a la isla
el buque razón y el primero en salir
desde el puerto de odessa con granos
ucranianos ha entrado ya en aguas
territoriales de turquía país que
supervisa el cumplimiento del acuerdo
para reabrir las exportaciones de
cereales estancadas desde el inicio de
la guerra ampliamos
la policía de nicaragua mantiene
asediado por orden de daniel ortega al
párroco de una iglesia perteneciente a
la diócesis de matagalpa a esa misma
diócesis pertenecen seis radios emisoras
cerradas el lunes por el gobierno
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 sé rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en asia
porque nancy pelosi presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu
aterrizó en la isla de taiwán pese a las
advertencias de beijing sobre
repercusiones graves pelosi que llegó
desde malasia en medio de su gira
asiática es la primera funcionaria
estadounidense de alto nivel que visita
la isla desde
1997 el gobierno chino reaccionó con
maniobras militares para la defensa
territorial nuestro corresponsal en
beijing adrián foncillas nos ampliaba
sobre la reacción de china
bueno la primera reacción es un
comunicado oficial del ministerio de
exteriores chino que ha sido lanzado
pocos minutos después de que pelosi
aterrizará en el aeropuerto señal de que
estaba ya preparado acusa a eeuu de
romper sus acuerdos de 1939 en los que
se prevé en visita hacer estadounidenses
no oficiales a la isla y hace ver que
difícilmente la de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- puede ser
considerada no oficial también repite
una vez más que taiwán es el asunto más
conflictivo entre las dos potencias
acusa a eeuu de frecuentar a los
independentistas y les recuerda que debe
respetar el principio de una sola china
no hay nada novedoso y tampoco sorprende
que china haya anunciado y al inicio de
maniobras militares en el estrecho de
formosa cabe subrayar el riesgo porque
en esa zona están juntando ya numerosos
barcos y aviones de guerra tanto de
china como eeuu como de taiwán y el
peligro no son las malas intenciones
sino un
o imprudencia
ya lo hemos visto en el mar del sur de
china cuando hemos estado a punto de
rozar la tragedia
porque barcos y aviones de china y eeuu
se han acercado mucho más de lo
recomendable ese o eso es en mi opinión
ahora lo más preocupante en eeuu hay
voces que afirman que el gobierno no ha
apoyado lo suficiente en la acción de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes- nuestra corresponsal en
nueva york' mamen sala no se amplia
si aquí hay quien habla de una débil
defensa por parte de la casa blanca en
este viaje de nancy pelosi a taiwán al
parecer y según ha revelado un alto
funcionario de washington el presidente
estadounidense y nancy pelosi no habrían
hablado antes de este viaje y tampoco
está previsto que lo hagan hemos
escuchado al portavoz del consejo de
seguridad nacional de eeuu john kirby
quien ha dicho que este viaje de nancy
pelosi a taiwán es congruente va de
acuerdo con la forma de tratar este caso
de la isla de taiwán por parte de
washington ha dicho que no tendría por
qué suponer ninguna crisis política para
que quien también la embajadora de eeuu
ex embajadora de eeuu ante las naciones
unidas ha dicho que la pataleta la
rabieta de china no va a conducir la
política exterior la política
internacional de eeuu así mismo también
el líder de la minoría en el senado
mitch mcconnell y 24 25 senadores más ha
firmado un comunicado en el que
mostraban su apoyo
viaje a taiwán también hemos podido leer
un artículo de opinión que la misma
nancy pelosi escribió para el washington
post y que se ha publicado justo después
de que ella aterrizará en la isla en el
que pelosi defiende este viaje dice que
es un símbolo de su apoyo del apoyo de
eeuu a la democracia el apoyo a un socio
democrático como esta y da da igual aquí
todos los medios de comunicación van con
el mismo titular pero si hace oídos
sordos a esas advertencias furiosas de
china y parece que da la sensación de
que preparan a la población para unas
consecuencias para una escalada de la
tensión entre las dos principales
potencias políticas a raíz de esta
visita un tenso equilibrio ha guiado
siempre el triángulo entre eeuu china y
taiwán la casa blanca oficialmente sólo
reconoce al gobierno chino pero mantiene
fuertes lazos con taiwán un territorio
de facto independiente
sobre el territorio de taiwán y su
estatus en el tablero internacional pese
a la ambigüedad es un territorio
independiente de facto con su propia
constitución y un sistema democrático
liberal aunque solo lo reconoce en 15
países
el resto incluido eeuu interlocutar
oficialmente solo con china que
considera a taiwán parte de su
territorio nacional el divorcio empezó
en 1949 cuando mao zhedong ganó la
guerra civil en china y el gobierno
derrocado se replegó en taiwán desde la
isla se reivindicaron como gobierno
único chino y apostaron por reconquistar
el territorio continental durante
décadas sin embargo el gobierno actuar
en taiwán tiene otros planes busca
abiertamente la independencia
y sigamos esforzándonos en proteger
nuestra patria haga una línea roja que
beijing no está dispuesta a cruzar bajo
ningún concepto
de hecho aprobó una ley que le permite
usar métodos no pacíficos y taiwán
intentará independizarse con un ejército
de unos 300.000 efectivos en la isla
sería un combate de david contra goliat
y precisamente por eso eeuu se
comprometió a garantizar la capacidad de
defensa militar de taiwán
washington vende armas con regularidad a
taipei y bailén incluso admitió que
estaría dispuesto a inter militarmente
siquiera invadiera el territorio algo
contradictorio con la política de una
sola china que la casa blanca dice
defender
nadie quiere que estalle en problemas en
el estrecho definitivamente no el
presidente de bailén
seguimos comprometidos con nuestra
política de una sola china y
continuaremos ayudando a taiwán con la
capacidad que necesita para defenderse
ahora la visita de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi a
taiwán hace peligrar el delicado
equilibrio logrado con esta diplomacia
ambigua y amenaza con devolver el
conflicto al estrecho de taiwán la
franja de mar de 180 kilómetros de media
que separa la isla del continente y por
donde pasan la mitad de los barcos
comerciales del mundo
el buque razón y el primero en salir
desde odessa con grano ucraniano desde
que se firmara el acuerdo mediado por la
onu y por turquía para reanudar las
exportaciones detenidas por la invasión
rusa llegó a la costa turca donde
aguarda ahora que inspectores examinen
la embarcación ampliamos desde estambul
con nuestro corresponsal
adrià
hace unas pocas horas que ha llegado a
las costas de estambul el barco carguero
con bandera de sierra leona pero que
partió ayer por la mañana del puerto de
odessa el carguero como decíamos razón y
que está ahora mismo esperando en la
desembocadura del estrecho del bósforo
en el mar negro para poder transitar
esta vía marítima una de las más famosas
del mundo no podrá hacerlo hasta que el
contenido del carguero que es de trigo y
grano exportado desde los silos de
ucrania sea inspeccionado por el centro
de coordinación conjunta establecido
hace algo más de una semana en estambul
con la participación de turquía y
naciones unidas como mediadoras en esta
este pacto que al que llegaron rusia y
ucrania rusia y ucrania que también
están representadas en este centro de
coordinación en estambul que abrió la
semana pasada varios miembros de este
comité irán mañana por la mañana a las 8
de la mañana hora de turquía sobre las
12 de la noche hora de bogotá a
investigar el contenido de este carguero
razón y en caso de que ucrania no mienta
como se espera que sea así que el
contenido de este el continuo de este
carguero es únicamente trigo él se
permitirá a partir de mañana a mediodía
por la mañana que el razón y transite
esta vía del estrecho del bósforo para
llegar primero lo has hecho de los
dardanelos después en dirección al mar
egeo pasando después por el mar
mediterráneo destino final trípoli en el
líbano un país muy necesitado del trigo
y del grano que lleva este este carguero
por un acre es grave crisis alimenticia
que vive no solo líbano se también
muchos países de áfrica y del ente el
próximo por el alto precio del trigo y
el grano que empezó sobre todo a
dispararse tras la invasión de rusia en
ucrania en febrero de este 2002 el
presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
ayer una exitosa operación
antiterrorista
ayman al-zawahiri considerado el maestro
del 11 de septiembre fue asesinado en un
ataque con drones el pasado sábado en
kabul en afganistán era conocido como la
persona que tomó el control de la
organización terrorista al qaeda tras el
asesinato de osama bin laden
una recompensa de 25 millones de dólares
por su cabeza diez años después de la
muerte de osama bin laden ayman
al-zawahiri murió en un ataque con
aviones no tripulados llevado a cabo por
eeuu en afganistán y
ahora se ha hecho justicia y este líder
terrorista ya no existe no importa el
tiempo que tome no importa donde se
escondan si son una amenaza para nuestro
pueblo eeuu los encontrará y eliminará a
new el
médico egipcio en su juventud radical
hizo rápidamente huyó de egipto a
mediados de la década de 1980 encontró
refugio en la ciudad paquistaní de
peshawar y ayudó a los combatientes
yihadistas muy ágil y no allí fue donde
conoció a osama bin-laden juntos
fundaron al qaeda y trabajaron varios
atentados mortales incluyendo los
ataques del 11 de septiembre que mataron
a casi 3.000 personas en nueva york en
2001 a las familias que perdieron padres
y madres maridos esposas hijos e hijas
hermanos y hermanas amigos y compañeros
de trabajo en aquel abrasador día de
septiembre espero que esta acción
decisiva aporte una medida más de cierre
hasta la muerte de bin laden el egipcio
siguió siendo su 'número dos' y jefe del
movimiento terrorista su muerte supone
un golpe muy duro para la organización
yihadista en un comunicado el portavoz
de los talibanes condenó al ataque
perpetrado en el suelo afgano por
estados unidos que considera viola el
derecho internacional
y la estrella de baloncesto británica en
el apareció en su séptima audiencia ante
el tribunal ruso desde que fue detenida
en moscú por tráfico de drogas eeuu la
considera como una presa política a la
espera de negociaciones entre moscú y
washington y del veredicto final de la
justicia rusa
una séptima audiencia para brittney
griner ante el tribunal dejen cerca de
moscú los últimos debates están
previstos para el jueves y el veredicto
final debería llegar en los próximos
días el juicio tomó una nueva dimensión
desde que moscú y washington empezaron
sus conversaciones sobre un posible
canje de prisioneros que incluye la
deportista sexto focos ella sigue
concentrada y todavía está nerviosa y
sabe que el final está cerca y por
supuesto se enteró de las noticias así
que espera que en algún momento pueda
volver a casa y nosotros también lo
esperaba mejor
concretamente el secretario de estado
estadounidense anthony blinken propuso
al ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov una oferta para lograr la
liberación de la basquetbolista y el
veterano paul wiland que sería a cambio
de entregar al traficante víctor boots
un ruso que fue declarado culpable de
tráfico de armas y que cumple una
condena de 25 años de prisión en eeuu
aunque rusia critica la manera en que
washington maneja la comunicación sobre
eventual canje
seguimos pensando que cualquier
intercambio de información sobre este
tema debe hacerse con discreción la
diplomacia megafón ame el intercambio
público de opiniones no logrará
resultados
whitney weiner fue detenida en un
aeropuerto de moscú en febrero con un
líquido de vaporizador a base de
cannabis la deportista se declaró
culpable de contrabando de drogas aunque
ha dicho repetidamente que no tenía la
intención de llevar a rusia un producto
prohibido se enfrenta a 10 años de
prisión en lo que eeuu considera como un
caso político que moscú usa como una
medida de presión y cerramos en
nicaragua la policía mantiene asediado
por orden de daniel ortega al párroco de
una iglesia perteneciente a la diócesis
de matagalpa el gobierno nicaragüense
ordenó el lunes el cierre de 6
radioemisoras adscritas a esta diócesis
andrés suárez jaramillo nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica nos dio
más detalles
la mente este es un nuevo episodio de la
denominada persecución religiosa que
está llevando a cabo la dupla ortega y
murillo en nicaragua en este momento
este martes se encuentra como usted bien
lo decía un ser con un asedio alrededor
de la iglesia divina misericordia en
sébaco esto es al norte del país
centroamericano y al interior de esta
casa cural está encerrado sin poder
salir el párroco de esta iglesia el cura
uriel vallejos él se encuentra con seis
personas pero no pueden salir los
policías les impiden el hecho de que
puedan incluso entrar alimentos y
bebidas y esto como una demostración de
fuerza de parte del gobierno
ortega murillo en contra de la diócesis
de matagalpa que es esta diócesis que es
dirigida por monseñor rolando josé
álvarez uno de los más fuertes críticos
de daniel ortega que de hecho desde el
año 2018 desde la crisis ha solicitado
la liberación de 190 presos políticos y
que a través de las radios católicas
envía un mensaje contrario al que
mantiene el gobierno de manera tal que
ya son 20 horas las que este párroco se
encuentra encerrado y 20 horas desde el
asedio en el cual irrumpieron fuerzas
antimotines con bases con balazos gases
lacrimógenos para apropiarse adueñarse
de todos los equipos de estas radios
católicas y que dejar por fuera a estas
radios de el sistema de
telecomunicaciones y correos telcor
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y a france 24
punto com
[Música]